[موسيقى]
رحيل المحاور الابرز ورائد الصحافه
التلفزيونيه وداعا مفيد فوزي والشفع عمر
ضيف ستوديو تفاعلكم اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
من ساعات في كنيسه المرعشلي في القاهره
تشييع جثمان الاعلامي المصري الكبير مفيد
فوزي والرحل صباح اليوم عن 89 عام
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
لا اله الا الله
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
المحاور ورائد الصحافه تلفزيونيه اثنين من
قائمه من الالقاب والاوصاف اللي على مدار
السنين اطلقت على مفيد فوزي الى انعرف
باسلوب مختلف وعملوا الصحفي والحوار اللي
تجاوز السياسه والاجتماع للفن والثقافه
والادب وغيرها وعلى مدار عشرات السنين
قدموا فيه فوزي حوارات كثيره حفرت في
ذاكره الملايين اللي او الى جانب برنامج
الشهير ايضا حديث المدينه اللي استمر على
شاشه التلفزيون المصري اكثر من 20 سنه
وميز في كل ما قدم اسلوب مختلف واسئله
اصبحت زي اللازمه او يعني العلامه المسجله
مثل السؤال
انه تسمح لي رساله هو بالطبع من وقت
الاعلان عن وفاته اسم الراحل ترند وعلى كل
من الصوت والنجوم ومشاهير وساسه
وترحموا عليه
وينضم الينا الاعلامي المصري تامر امين
اهلا فيك معانا تامر واول شيخ خليني ابتدي
بتعازينا الحاره انا عارفه انها مش بس
خساره مهنيه هي ايضا خساره شخصيه بالنسبه
لك
اهلا ساره تحياتي لك ولساده المشاهدين في
كل مكان يا خساره
انسانيه الى شئت التعبير الاستاذ مفيد كان
قيمه انسانيه كبيره جدا جدا جدا بكل البشر
وكان مؤثرا وكان حاضرا وكان ملئما لنا
جميعا وعلى المستوى الانساني
كبيره جدا من العلاقه الشخصيه الوطيده
اللي كانت طردتني به مش بس استاذي ومعلمي
وملهمي
استاذ توفيق كان يعني ولد الثاني بعد ما
فقدت والدي برده سنوات رحمه الله عليه
الاستاذ مفيد حل محله وكان والدي في
الحياه وكان والدي في الاعلام
وكمان جماعتنا الزمالك المهنيه اخر سنتين
لما كنت بشارك حضرتك في الفقره الاسبوعيه
اللي بيعملها برنامج كلام مفيد
ورحيل ورحيل ساترك اثر كبير جدا جدا فيا
وفي كل المحيطين الاعلام العربي
اخر مداخله لويا تامر كانت معاك ايضا في
البرنامج وكان حتى فيها ضحك وكان عنده
لازال روح متفائله وكان بتكلم منه حيخضع
لعمليه وما الى ذلك وحتى انت يعني كنت
بتحاول انك تقول له انه يلا ان شاء الله
تقوم وترجع لنا هل تواصلتم بعد هذه
المكالمه اللي كانت على الشاشه
اللي كان على الشاشه ده كان من اجل العمل
وكنت بحاول اطمئن الجماهير والمشاهدين على
صحه الاستاذ مفيد اللي كان داخل يعمل
عمليه في القنوات المراريه وزي ما انت قلت
كان في منتهى المرح وفي منتهى الطاقه
والتفاؤل لدرجه حتى ان هو صاحب
الفسحه الجميله اللي حتى المرض اللي بيجيء
لي له علاقه بالقنوات والاعلان
ده انا كنت باتواصل معه ومع حنان صديقتي
واختي يعني همم
اه كريمه الاستاذ مفيد
كنت باتواصل معها انا وكريم برنامج طول
الوقت عشان اطمن عليه والاخبار الحقيقه ان
هو كان يعني في حاله مستقره لكن الاعمار
بيد الله
طيب تامر يعني الاعلاميين كثار جدا بس
قليل النجوم وقليل اللي بيتركه
خاصه فيهم مفيد فوزي ليش عمل هذه الحاله
كيف قدر يعملها ايش ميزه
لا يعني
ايش ميزو دي ممكن نكتب فيها مجلدات
الاستاذ مفيد
الاستاذ مفيد اهم اهم ميزه في انه كان طول
الوقت مفيد فوزي لم يكن شخص اخر ولم يبحث
عن التقليد ولم يبحث عن محاوله يعني
الاجاده لمساحات ااخص اخرى
كان احد يقدر يجلدو
الكامله في الصحافه وفي الكتابه وكان فارس
القلم وفارس الكلمه بلا منازع وجمع
الاجابه كمان المتالقه في العمل الاعلامي
التليفزيوني عايز اقول لك ان كل البرامج
اللي احنا بنعملها دلوقتي انا وزملائي
عمرو اديب ولميس كل برامج التوك تودي كلها
خرجت من رحم من البرنامج اللي علمنا يعني
ايه برامج اهتمامات الناس وهو برنامج
الاشهر حديث المدينه الاستمر في تقديمه
اكثر من 20 سنه
فالحقيقه الاستاذ مفيد كان كان متفرد وكان
صادق وكان جريء وكان لا يؤمن بشيء الا
يفعله وكان ما عندوش فكره التردد ابدا
وكان دائما صاحب
الاسئله اللي انا بسميها الرصاصات
التلفزيونيه والصحفيه كان سباك باجراء
الحوارات اللي
بشملت كل النجوم العالم في السياسه والفن
والادب لدرجه حتى انه في اخر لقاء
تلفزيوني بينده في البرنامج عندي انا قلت
له الواحد يا استاذ مفيد يعني ما يتمناش
سي في التليفزيون
مثل السيره الذاتيه الاعلام
لا ما شاء الله يعني هو يعني للنهايه
يستمر حاضر الذهن وقادر على
العطاء وهذا يعني كان يعني ظاهر حتى في
مشاركاته وايضا في
برنامجك انت تحدثت الان عن الرصاصات
الاسئله اللي هي زي الرصاصات واللي معروف
فيها وفعلا هو جريء يقول اسمح لي اسالك
وبعدين يضرب قنبله يعني هل حكى لك شيء مره
عن مثلا كواليس واحده من المقابلات او
واحده من المشاكل اللي صارت له بسبب مثلا
سؤال من هذه الاسئله
طيب
طيب احنا فقدنا الاتصال مع تامر بس خلينا
مشاهدينا نحنا حناخد وقفه مع نقطه من بحر
ارشيف الراحل مفيد فوزي معظم حياته يسال
الاسم بالكامل فؤاد زكي المهندس
العمر
الحاله الاجتماعيه
والله نحبها
الاستاذ حسام
[موسيقى]
لماذا طلقت
للاعلامي المصري انا كنت بسالك على هذه
الرصاصات واحنا عرضنا مقطع من هذه
الرصاصات يعني لما نقول لعمرو دياب يعني
لماذا طلقت يعني عمر دياب ما كان عنده رد
في البدايه عشان يستوعب الا انه يعيد
السؤال يعني هو في حاله ظهور فهل حكى لك
شيء عن كواليس مشاكل او طرائف من هذه
الرصاصات
اللي انا تشرفت ان هو همم جمال ان فيها
على مدار سنتين في برنامج اخر النهار على
شاشه النهار كان الهدف الاساسي منها لما
فكرنا فيها كانت همم حديث الذكريات ان هو
يجيء ويحكي لي على كل المواقف وكل
الكواليس وكل الاسرار والانفرادات اللي هو
عملها على مدار تاريخه وبعد كده لما انا
استاذنت بالفقره تبقى ثابته ودائمه مساء
كل اربعاء طورناها بقى للاسم اللي كان
موجود لحد الاسبوع اللي فاتت فقره الكلام
مفيد وكان هو اللي بيختار الموضوع وهو
اللي بيختار ال- همم العناوين اللي
بنعيشها وكانت بتتحول الى دردشه مفتوحه
بيني وبينه علشان طول الوقت يبقى في حاله
التفاعل على الاسم البرنامج اسئلته
وطول الوقت كنت باتعلم منه ازاي يسال
وازاي يخرج المعلومه كان واحد من الارقام
اللي انا باحب اطلق عليه جدا فكره الباحث
عن الحقيقه لانه من اكثر الناس اللي
استطاعت انها تخرج من سجن ضيوفه واستطاع
اللي هو ببراءه شديده يجبرهم على التكلم
بمنتهى الاريحيه
كان بعض الناس يقولوا على اسلوبه ان في
شيء من الاستفزاز
وانا رايي الحقيقه انه دي كانت من احد
مزاياه النادره
همم الاعلامي عليه ان يكون همم
متملك شويه لقدره على الاستفزاز الضيوف
حتى يستطيع ان يخرج ما بداخلهم لانه
المذيعين الحريري لا مجال له وسط همم
الغابات اللي احنا بنعيش فيها دلوقت
احطها من الحكم اللي تعلمناه اليوم او
اللي لازم نوثقها اليوم سريعا تامر اذا
قلت لك اكثر شيء اتعلمته منه اعتز فيه
اكثر شيء تعلمته منه رغم ان اللي تعلمته
كثير بس اللي انا اتعلمته انه
قول ما تقتنع انه الصواب حتى لو انت عارف
انك هتتهالي وتنتقد كان الاستاذ مفيد يقول
كلام قبل الهواء يقول لي انا الكلام اللي
انا هقوله ده هيجيب لي وجع دماغ الناس مش
هيعجبها قوي بس انا هقوله عشان انا عارف
ان فيه مصلحه والمنفعها وانا الحقيقه
اعتقد ان انا ماشي على هذا الضرب همم لا
يهمك رضا الناس بقدر ما يهمك رضا الرب
[موسيقى]
ذكرياتكم مواقفك مع الراحل كان معنا
الاعلامي المصري تامر
مفيد وتذكره دائما بخير شكرا لك
اهلا من جديد عمر ابو لبده صانع محتوى
سوري بس محتوى من كل الناس يمكن بتحبه وما
في خلاف عليه ببساطه لانه عمر شاف ومين ما
بحب الاكل يعني لكن لازم نعطي كل شيء حقهم
يقول انه في وقت صار فيه كثير شافات من
نجوم وصانعي المحتوى عمر متميز ومختلف
وبحسابات معاونها دائما من سوريا لكل
العالم من هنا بدا التغيير عمر بيقدم
محتوى بيسميه ثوره في عالم الطبخ العربي
وبرامج الطبخ التقليديه
جربت شاورما تبعها تايو لواء اسكندرون
والله شكلك مجربه
تاخذ هاي
[موسيقى]
من قبل محاشي على طريقه مرتي فقررنا انه
لازم نعمل محاشي على طريقه امي يعني تمام
له له له له له
تاخد اللقمه يا غالي وبتدحبرها بصوابعك شو
بتساوي
بتسجعها بافمك صباح الخير
اسرع كبه بالعالم ممكن تجربه بحياتكم
سنه بصل
لحمه ملح وفلفل اسود وقرفه وشويه جوزه
الطيب
الاسلوب الجديد والمميز والمحتوى المختلف
ساعد عمر انه يصير واحد من اهم شيفات
العالم العربي على السوشيال ميديا حساباته
ما شاء الله عليها ملايين المتابعين ان
كان من فيسبوك الي عليه 7 مليون متابع
تقريبا ليوتيوب اللي عليه مليون و600 الف
مشترك واكثر من 273 مليون مشاهده اما
انستقرام فعليه مليون وشوي متابعه عليه
ثلاثه مليون لايك تقريبا والنجاح ما شاء
الله منورنا
الان لما قلت لك كده الارقام لما استعرضت
الارقام ايش حسيت كثير
خلينا نقول انه
المشاهدات صفر صفر صفر ايش كان احساسك انا
كنت عم بعمل شيء
بحبه فما كنت كثير مهتم للموضوع لكن شوي
شوي شوي شوي صار خلاص لازم يكون في شيء
افضل من هيك ههه بتشتغل على حالي اكثر
واكثر واكثر حتى اليوم من الايام
وبعدين خلاص صار في المتابعين والكلام ده
كله وصلت
بدها تكون احب مدرسه خاصه ايش المدرسه
خاصه هذه مدرسه البساطه يعني انا مو بس
انه بدخل كمان ان نكتب يقلب الطبخ لا حتى
البساطه يعني بسهلك الموضوع بمسك هي اهم
شغله انه الشيف يعطي المتفرش طاقه ايجابيه
يعني لكن ناس بتقول لك انا لما بشوفك او
بشوفوني بايدي انا ما بشوفك بحس بده يفوت
على المطبخ بسوي اكل بده يطبخ بتحمم
مختلفه بهارات مختلفه تركيبتها مختلفه
طعمات مختلفه دائما
ناجحين بهذا الشكل واهتمام كبير حتى على
التيك توك حتى على الانستغرام
كانه ظاهره هلا هي مو ظاهره شوفي الوصفات
القصيره
يعني الفيديوهات القصيره انا بالنهايه ما
بعتبرها وصفه يعني انا بساوي هلا فيديوهات
قصيره لكن هي مالها وصفي ميه بالميه
الوصفه لازم بدها شرح بدي تفاصيل بده يكون
فيه دقه يعني انه هاي لازم هيك لازم هيك
لكن بطريقه مبسطه لا توصل للشخص دائما لما
يطلع الشيف ويعطيكي مكونات
وتكون المكونات صعبه خلاص انت بتطلعي من
الفيديو طيبه
[ضحك]
انك محاط اصلا بعائله فيها طباخين ممتازين
يعني الوالده طباخه وزوجتك ايضا برضو
طباخه بس مين احسن احد فيكم
همم شغل بطريقه صحيحه وعلميه اكيد انا
لانه انا درست هذا الشيء يعني هذا اختلافي
عن والدتي مثلا والدتي تعلمت من والدتها
والدتها تعلمت من 60 وهيك يعني بجره
العاده لكن انا يعني غير الشيء اللي اخذته
من انا وهو صغير مكنته بيشيل علمي دائما
بيشيل علمي لازم يكون موجود
انت حتى في فيديوهاتك على فكره بتتكلم عنه
اكثر من مره بتعلق انه لا يا جماعه انا
دارس هذا الشيء وانه انا دارس وكان في
دروس نظريه وبعدين دروس عمليه وما الى ذلك
بس كاني حسيت انك انت بتحس انه الشخص اللي
دارس اكيد افضل واشطر من الشخص اللي
مودارس
انه انت شو دارس كيف درس تدفع انا لازم
اعطيهم جواب مقابل هذا الشيء هلا هو ما في
داعي يعطي جواب اللي شايف اللي بيعرف من
لما بيشوفني شو عم بحكي مثلا معلومه انه
كيف صدر الدجاج ينطبخ
الستات البيوت
بدون ما يغطي الطنجره فهي يعني هي النقط
جدا
الصراحه لازم انك تدرسيها يعني كثير قصص
يعني بحر الطبخ
مين بيني وبين مين يعني
في البيت
[ضحك]
عندها شغلات كثير طيبه وزوجتي كمان تعمل
اكلات يعني مثلا زي هيك بتعمل يبرق ومحاشي
بيطلع معك كثير طيب طيب
كثير كثير
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
اذا كان معنا الشيف عمر شكرا لك مشاهدينا
انا اعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]